three books dick false Bree's eponymous
technique won him the Olympic gold medal
in 1968 at a time when this was the norm
he couldn't have been more different
to demonstrate The Fosbury Flop we
sought out Dalton Grant look at this
oh I don't know if it fits me
fits me still
a former Commonwealth high jump Champion
first the run-up then the leap backwards
and head first yay
for me how I felt I felt comfortable it
was like flying over your you know in
the air so once you went over and you
lean off the curve and you hit that that
take off that sweet spot you use your
free fire shoulder tie arms and then you
elevate the moment momentum from the
ground off the curve tilts you into that
rainbow take over the bar and then you
just you're just flying it seems like
you're up there for so long
before the Flop was the scissor kick and
also the western roll techniques that
now seem hard to believe existed
part of what led to fosbury's new
jumping style was the introduction of
this
the crash mat which gave him something
soft to land on but at the time his new
technique was still considered hugely
dangerous with some warning it would
lead to a Spate of broken necks
his determination to reach New Heights
has left a legacy well beyond sport
most people have heard of Dick Fosbury
or he might use the phrase The Fosbury
Flop technique before former high jumper
turned motivational speaker Steve Smith
is among the many in the corporate world
who use him as a study in Innovation
well I think I've used a call from dick
Fosbury pretty much uh every week for
maybe the last 15 years so he uses a
metaphor for Innovation he's uses a
metaphor for doing things differently
but he also uses a metaphor for
challenging those who can't adapt to new
ways of working
his new way of working did eventually
become the norm at first seen as a freak
Show The Fosbury Flop was soon the
future either Bennett Sky News